C'est un...ho ho ho.Oui alo. Femme: bonjour. Squeezie: bonjour
Femme: bonjour je suis sabrina votre conseillere SFR
Très bien. Heu... Alors...
GO GO Mickalow
Ok je te voie. P***** mais t'est loin toi. Mickalow: je tente le toit
Attend moi aussi je tente le toit. Mais mec je tente le balcon je suis à... NOPE. Nan c'est raté
Mickalow: mais moi je suis bloquer dans les air. Mais non tu rigole. Mais p***** micka. Explose de rire.
*Squeezie lit* Tout est de ta faute.
Et c'est repartit
C'est la fête aujourd'hui c'est la saint Lucas aujourd'hui allez on y va.
HAAAAA. On dirait le début d'un mauvais hentaï tu sais. Je regarde pas de hentaï c'est faux.
Maxence: tu sais un jour il faudra que tu tente un faceswap
Avec ton jackie chan. Squeezie: HA oui. *squeezie mort de rire*
Maxenss: nan mais c'est...
*squeezie chiale de rire*
On dirait macron. Je ressemble a macron.
Qu'est ce quelle fait
*La fille pète*
Je l'ai vécu comme une agression. Je me suis fait agresser. HO p*****
Florent Hauchard: la dégustation ce fait pour tout spécimène. *Squeezie rit*
Florent Hauchard: Cet énergumène par exemple à manger un bout de taureau sauvage.
Mec j'ai envie de me giffler. J'ai envie de me mettre des claques
Et de me couper la mèche
*Squeezie crie*
FILS DE PUTE!
Mickalow : "Il saigne le salop"
HAAAAAAA micka j'ai eu peur
Ok les amis on est en train de voler, on est en apesanteur
WOOOOOOOOW
WOOO
Squeezie : "HOLLY SHIT"
Du coup j'ai eu ma petite vengeance on voit ta tête quand tu as vraiment
Heu... 14 ans
Florent: Nan mais attend tu va la mettre sur le net. Squeezie: ha bien sûr
Florent: ha daccord ta aucun respect pour ton frère
Ha on peut gagner on est plus que 5. Est ce que le guide va gagner
*frustré* Je pleure pas parce que je suis déçu
Je pleure car j'ai frolée la crise cardiaque
*squeezie lit* Ta sûrment raison on était suposait aller chez un ami et faire la fête
Et me laisser seule comme ça. Elle va peut être nous proposer de venir
*squeezie lit* tant fais pas j'ai mon téléphone
*musique de rateau*
Cette video c'est un couteau permanent dans le coeur quoi
*rire*
MCfly: a l'enculé !
Carlito: mais pecs il sont pas flasque OK. Squeezie: c'est vrai (x2) je me suis trompés
je me suis trompés
NYO: juste une question c'est une femme ou un mec
Squeezie: c'est une chose Attend ils sont oû
Mickalow: le rocher devant. Squeezie: je vois (x2)
Attend mec j'ai une gre j'ai une gre je tente une gre  ou pas aller micka je tente une gre
Attend micka bouge pas je lançe une gre
Micka cours j'ai rater
* vois roque* Les tables nous envahissent
NAN NAN les armées n'ont pas réussis a nous défendre
Et ce que on et destiner a devenir des tables basse
Une table basse quelqu'un veut de l'eau
En faite il va y avoir des forme qui vont arriver dessus et il va faloir les esquiver
Tout ça en rythme avec une musique. On peut choisir la musique
Ha je suis chaud mon gars. Ha c'est la meilleur vidéo de ma chaîne youtube c'est sûr c'est c'elle si
On... (Squeezie a perdu c'est mot)
Hé hé *BIP* Natoo: je suis céline dion au pôle emploi
*Natoo s'enjaille*
du hocket sous l'eau mais comment tu peut faire du hocket sous l'eau
Cyprien: il y a pas foule
Squeezie: faite du bruit
Faite du bruit pour nos champion
Cyprien: c'est quoi ça???
Squeezie: c'est pour retirer le givre le matin sur ta voiture le matin
Cyprien: il y a un mec qui a regarder ça  il a fait: "P***** je te mais un tubas et je te fais un sport"   *squeezie rit*
les mecs la on dirait... Tu connais même pas ton équipe???
Squeezie: en faite moi se qui me fais mourir rire c'est quand même il ont mis une chanson rock and roll
tu sais jore faut être un bad guy et tout pour faire ça.
laisse moi en paix
paaaaaiiiiiiiiiiix
fils de p***. HAAAAAAAAA
HAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Dans l'eau.
*squeezie rit*
A c'est génial *BIP* Ha tu peut utiliser et tournez les caméras
Mickalow: HAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
HAA il est là
Squeezie: HAAAAAAA HAAAAAAAAAA
Mickalow: je t'avais dit de l'attraper
*langue étrangère* *squeezie rit*
Attend le mec il a dit Osaka. Osaka c'est
une très grosse ville au japon du coup je me suis dit c'est du japonais
c'est du japonais un peu danois quand même
Evidamment c'est du danois mec
ho non je me suis payer la honte
ho le carma. *BIP*  qu'est ce qu'il faut faire en vrai. Presse P pour
pour sortir ton p****
c'est quoi ce jeu en faite
julien: c'est un acteur français que vous aimez bien. pas sportif du tout
Heuuuuuuuuuuu...
norman thaveau
Natoo: ça dénonce
Ho le bâtard *bip* ton visage on dirait un chameau
Merci nyo on ne feras plus jamais de vidéo ensemble
Toi t'est qui toi d'en E-Sport
Ho m****
qu'est ce qu'il fait tout allait bien jusqu'à que tu fasse ça
Mais aidez le. Laisse loi te relevez
Pardon je voulais juste le relever c'est contagieux ou pas
je veux t'aider mais je crois que je peut juste de taper
Je suis en train de t'aidez
Il vont arriver
HA HA micka
t'est près a 3. 1 2 3
*micka meurt*
désoler micka
Je t'aime
Cyprien: je fait une activiter. Je l'ai déjà fait?
Julien: Ho oui *natoo rit*
*natoo rit*
*BIP* olala qu'est ce que ça fait mal de se faire couper la jambe
olala qu'est ce que ça fait...
J'ai mal je saigne j'ai mal partout au mon dieu c'est térrible il faut déshinfecter
*Squeezie rit*
ouiii
J'ai mal a la jambe m****
*explose de rire*
une valeur sûr gros seins
meilleur choix de perssonages
tu as dit gros seins ? GROS SEINS
J'en êtait sûr mec
Je le savait
*Squeezie rit*
*musique douce*
des mites (la blague nul)
Haa J'ai pas crier c'etait une manière de s'exprimer
c'est juste une manière commune de dire
olala je suis surpris
*BIP*
Il est mort
Il va pas bien du tout
ça vien du japon je me méfie
*musique la danse des canards*
Natoo: encore
charabia
Salut c'est la bromance
squeezie ou cyprien
cyprien
et voilà comme 58% des gens on voter
il est pas si ouf se site en vrai
Et ce que je peut dire ma phrase gentille pour nathalie. Natoo...
Fais ce que tu veux avec cette info "ça ma fait mal"
La reponse et à l'envers
HOOOO il a compris du premier coup
Je peut voir la fiérter dans tes yeux
*langue étrangère*
non mais mec tu va me l'enfoncer dans le palais
J'ai jamais était aussi peut serein en mangeant une olive
Je sais pas ce que ça veut dire mais ce dictionnaire a êtait diriger par alain Rey
Gros big-up a alain rey aller vous abonner a son twittter
je ne sais pas
ça veut dire quoi dirigez en faite
Les mots il existe déjà mec
Les gars on vas faire les D aujourd'hui
lol dsl il y a encore le fond vert
mais mec tu peut pas faire ça
tu peut pas faire ton montage et dire dsl il y a encore le fond vert
Je l'avais fais dans la vidéo d'avant
*rire*
qui a mis ça
*s'arrache la gorge de rire*
*rire+désesperance d'amixem*
*rire*
Ho p***** c'est toi
je sais pas (x2)
mec
c'est le seul mec quand il est pas inspirer il est genial
il mais oui. *BIP* je peut avoir une photo
de la boule au montage
il est mort. Oui. Tu savais pas
Tu savais pas
*Langue étrangère*
Alors devinez devinez
Je suis en train de bouillir a l'intérieur c'est térrible
Ca c'est le 3ème youtubeur de france
qui rigole
charabia
peace
Hooo la lumière
Merci a lilalilo pour les sous-titre bisous